ils étaient des milliers réunis près du
parlement à l'appel de maya sandhu élu à
la tête du pays le 15 novembre dernier
ce dimanche chisinau capitale de la
moldavie a de nouveau été le théâtre
d'une mobilisation contre la majorité
actuelle
les manifestants réclament la démission
du gouvernement et la dissolution du
parlement dans le viseur des partisans
de maya sand ou des nouvelle loi
réduisant les pouvoirs présidentiels
l'une d'elles actes notamment le
transfert du contrôle du service de
renseignement et de sécurité aux députés
un parlement moldave qui restent acquis
à la cause du gordo donnent le président
sortant
ce dernier concentre d'ailleurs la
plupart des critiques de la nouvelle
dirigeante et sa glace daniel kalt ses
chers concitoyens la corruption dans
laquelle john a plongé notre pays
constitue une menace pour nous tous
c'est un danger mortel pour chisinau
pour la gagaouzie pour balti le pays
s'essouffle le pays ne peut pas se
développer en ayant des autorités de ce
type ça qu elle doit à l'appel de la
présidente élue des personnes avaient
déjà manifesté cette semaine contre ce
projet de loi controversé
un texte proposé par le parti socialiste
qui soutient et gordon
face à ces premières protestations le
président sortant avait appelé au calme
j'appelle la présidente élue maya sont
doux à ne pas faire descendre les gens
dans la rue à ne pas les exposer à des
risques en pleine pandémie et à tout
faire pour maintenir le calme dans la
société
il n'y a aucune logique à organiser des
manifestations maintenant et ses actions
ne mèneront à rien de bon n'avons
absolument pas besoin de déstabilisation
et de chaos
maya sans doute favorable à un
rapprochement avec l'union européenne a
été élu avec 57 % des suffrages
mi-novembre face à igor dodon
ex-ministre elle a fait campagne sur la
lutte contre la corruption dans ce pays
de 3,5 millions d'habitants l'un des
plus pauvres du vieux continent
la première femme président de moldavie
doit être officiellement investi le 23
décembre prochain